heute stellen wir eine ziemlich
vertrackte frage um die ist was würdest
du gerne machen wenn du keine angst
hättest und das bedeutet genau es geht
darum ob menschen in ihrem leben das
gefühl haben irgendwas verpasst zu haben
weil sie sich nicht getraut haben
irgendwas zu machen was sie machen
wollten
ok los geht's
[Musik]
was würden sie gerne machen wenn sie
keine angst davor hätten
also mein sohn möchte sobald er 16 ist
vom forum hotel springen und es ist so
es ist mir so unterstellt ist zu tun und
ich glaube wenn ich das nicht trauen
würde war ich total begeistert aber sie
würden das im prinzip gerne machen wenn
sie keine angst hätten die daten so
furchtbar aber ich bewundere ihn so dass
er sich das trau dass ich alles ist es
ist mir ich kann es nicht mal denken was
würdest du gerne machen wenn du keine
angst davor hat ist ja das ist richtig
schwer
zb den bungee jump von der brücke wo ich
für viele war spontan und einfach mal
machen und nicht überlegen was werden
die konsequenzen einfach mal ein
bisschen wilder sein und das leben
genießen und nicht so vernünftig sein
was für dich machen nicht mehr trauen
generell aber das ist aber hast du ein
konkretes beispiel
ich würde den job wechseln was machst du
gerade
gerade aber ich drei berufe
freiberuflich als künstlerin und ich
würde in die musik gehen
ich würde meine musik machen versuche
mit musik geld zu verdienen
das würde ich gerne noch nicht keine
angst hätte vielleicht
fallschirmspringen die die frage ist was
würdest du gerne machen wenn du keine
angst hättest also ich glaube bei mir
fängt anderen würde ich glaube ich
autofahren tatsächlich gern bisher noch
nicht auto fahren aber ich glaube da
würde ich überhaupt mal ist probieren
und mich auf diese dieses gefährliche
pflaster der der straße wagen aber ist
glaube ich das ist nur meine spontane
antwort ich glaube wenn ich keine angst
hätte das ständemehr die welt offen aus
dem flugzeug springen
das haben heute viele gesagt vor
menschen singen kann zu singen es liegt
im auge des betrachters in dem fallen
was wäre das mehr über mein leben
alleine bestimmt wegen meine eltern so
zum beispiel dass die wir noch viel vor
schreiben bzw was wir erwarten und ich
hätte manchmal gerne so ein wenig freier
gerne so ein bisschen uns aber mehr
trauen also dich ein bisschen mehr
durchsetzen
aufsteigen auf die berge hinaufsteigen
zum beispiel welche berge hast du hören
angst tatsächlich ein bisschen aber ich
habe sie auch schon teilweise überwunden
und wie hast du deine angst überwunden
indem ich einfach den schritt gewagt
habe auf die berge hoch zu fahren also
mit dem reisebus
ich würde zum beispiel die sichere
arbeit lassen und keine ahnung
eine andere erfahrung im leben was was
machst du beruflich ich bin erzählt ich
würde wahrscheinlich so bungee jumping
und sowas leicht machen aber auch so was
sie auswandern
also echt ganz viele sachen wohin
würdest du auswandern weiß ich nicht
etwas was du gerne machen würdest dich
aber nicht traust was wäre das ich weiß
nicht soll waren fahren also was ganz
einfach ist also die höhe also ich
fliege kein problem aber irgendwo hört
es dann darauf also ich weiß nämlich
wird vielleicht ja selber gefahren oder
über sein großer höhe laufen haben sich
vielleicht ein anderes beispiel
vielleicht etwas was sie nicht gemacht
haben weil sie sich nicht getraut haben
ich glaub ich möchte so eigentlich nicht
über mein leben denken ja also ich
möchte ja auch nicht decken
das ist jetzt ganz schlimm das hast du
nicht gemacht und die chance hast du nie
wieder ich möchte ihr denken auch aus
irgendeinem grund habe ich es nicht
gemacht und es wird gut sein weil damals
war das zuviel für mich aber vielleicht
kann ich mir ja das heute anders geben
oder gang oder sowas will ich sogar
gerne einfach mal irgendwo einen zug
setzen und hinfahren und dann steigt
hier aus und dann wahrscheinlich wieder
ein und so weiter einfach nicht planen
nur die reise hingeht sondern mich
einfach deswegen der weg ist das ziel
auch macht das am wochenende schon okay
gibt nehme ich mir vor ich da ich nie
war und vereinfacht los na ja ich hatte
also ich hatte mal ein sehr sehr schönen
abend in einem club mit einer sehr
schönen begleitung und das musste ich
aber abbrechen mich am nächsten tag
arbeiten musste und ich angst um meinen
job zu verlieren also dass das hätte ich
dann gerne mal gemacht ja also ich hätte
gerne noch mehr zeit miteinander
verbracht dort ging dann leider nicht
weil ich hart arbeiten musste und das
ist ja vielleicht auch was was man dann
aus angst macht und sonst was vielleicht
etwas was du in deinem leben bereut hast
weil du dich nicht getraut hast das zu
machen
na ja verschiedene leute ansprechen die
ihr auto auf der straße begegnen wo man
sich vielleicht nicht traut wie wir
jetzt gerade machen ja schwierig frage
doch spinne ich die schlechteste
sängerin aber ich habe wahnsinnig alle
angst davor vor anderen menschen zu
singen und welches lied würdest du gerne
singt i close von adams
30 machen trau dich ich trau dir die
haare blau zu färben ja hatte ich auch
schon mal so richard sie weiß es war gut
aber was mir aufgefallen ist ist das ist
ziemlich schwer war dafür zu sorgen dass
die leute die frage wirklich verstanden
haben
aber man hat dann gemerkt nachdem sie
einen moment überlegt haben dass sie
dass sie verschiedene ideen hatten und
jeder hat was anderes gesagt ich fand es
interessant dass die älteren leute sich
geweigert haben quasi zu sagen ich
bedaure etwas nicht gemacht zu haben
das war mein leben und das ist auch gut
so
na gut leute dann wir verabschieden uns
jetzt von euch vergisst nicht zu sagen
vergiss nicht einsieht lake projekt
auszuprobieren und wir sagen tschüss
[Musik]